we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
this is a new favorite caller of mine
this is one of the most confident
callers i've ever had this caller says
he is the authority on ufos and aliens
and he is going to now beyond any doubt
tell us the truth the truth about ufos
listen to this
yeah david great show i don't watch too
often i'm too busy but i have another
follow-up comment about ufos
loves the show never watches it that's
okay i'll take the praise uh you could
bank on this and i am good when i do my
research
i consider myself the best i already
have a proven track record the evolution
of our solar system before the earth was
formed and all the planet
has never repeat has never been
visited by probes or
observations from any
repeat any
extraterrestrial society
in the entire universe or from
these
bologna
theories about multi-universes or
fourth-dimensional b
never
there had never been a ufo that landed
on this planet no probes no pass-bys
nothing
there's no aliens living on this planet
okay all right i think i think you get
it i really appreciate the caller
confidently putting that to rest and i
know there are people in our audience
with different perspectives on this
issue but this call
if you go by his confidence he must be
completely correct we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today sarah huckabee
sanders says that if she is governor
kids in the womb will be as safe as kids
in classrooms
wait a second that something about that
is not making sense we will discuss it
we have a study that finds that when a
state passes a concealed carry law gun
crime goes up by 33 percent and we will
also talk about the belief among more
than half of americans that the supreme
court
is coming for gay marriage sooner or
later after the roe v wade decision that
the supreme court is coming for gay
marriage i happen to agree
and we will talk about that on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpackman.com
will get instant access to the bonus
show that is a freaking predator right
now not predatory at all if you like it
then you keep it that's how it is use
the coupon code big voting 22 to sign up
at joinpakman.com
get instant access to the bonus show and
then if all goes well i will be back
here with you tomorrow